products like these have become the
latest casualty as the international
backlash against the new delhi
government grows
supermarkets in kuwait are removing
indian made goods as a way to protest
islamophobia
is obligatory for every muslim and every
country because this is a matter
concerning the prophet
the global outcry has prompted prime
minister narendra modi's party janta
party to take action against two members
accused of making inflammatory comments
national spokeswoman nupur sharma has
been suspended while the party's media
head in new delhi naveem kumar jindal
has been expelled the bjp says it
strongly denounces insults against any
religious personalities as well as
ideology that demeans any sect or
religion but critics say the response is
too little too late
countries in the gulf region including
qatar and iran have summoned their
indian envoys and demanded a public
apology clearly there is a mutuality of
economic interest
mutuality of security interests
between india and the gulf countries and
that
interest
is shown in growing in the growing
relationship between india and the gulf
states
i don't see that that is going to go
away
because of this incident
also i think that both both india and
the gulf states need to see this in a
perspective and contain the fallout
several international rights groups have
documented the rise in hate speech and
violence against minorities since the
bjp came to power in 2014. the u.s state
department draws similar conclusions in
its annual report which was released
last week however the indian government
has rejected these accusations
journalist mohammed zubair says the bgp
had no choice but to take action against
the two politicians the action now uh
was after 11 days only because there was
some international pressure i'm sure
we've been trending this and we've been
asking questions i mean for 10 days
there was no response but then they've
been actually uh and raising them
supporting them
only because of this international
pressure i would say there was action
opposition parties have urged the
government to take responsibility they
say the bjp's political discourse has
made incidents like these commonplace
and have now embarrassed india
internationally pavani mithal al-jazeera
new delhi